Standards evolved over many years to encompass more aspects of medicine,
to code them in more detail,
and to adapt as technology changed.
We will divide this evolution into three dimensions.
Structure, purpose, and technology.
We will discuss the first two in this segment,
and technology evolution in the next one.
The structure of standards has evolved in
large part to take advantage of the capabilities of computing.
Early data standards were lists such as medical diagnoses,
laboratory tests, or medications.
We will refer to those list standards as classifications.
As the use of computers and health care grew,
so did interest in the standards community to describe
more detail and to represent relationships among clinical concepts.
We will refer to a standard that can code for relationships as an ontology.
The goal here is often semantic interoperability,
as we saw in Lesson two.
You may remember this graph of clinical relationships from the Applicadia video,
and their nuanced multi-layered representation of
clinical details, concepts, and relationships.
Note here that Applicadia is using both ICD-10 and SNOMED to represent concepts.
These are both ontologies that are able to represent
concepts relationships which is at the core of what Applicadia is trying to do.
The purpose of standards has also evolved.
Pre-computing, all of the early standards were for data.
Physicians would use the International Classification of Disease,
ICD, in their charting, primarily for billing.
The clinical laboratory would use a classification with the acronym,
LOIC, for their tests.
And the pharmacy would use one of
several relatively simple classifications to represent the medications they dispensed.
In the 1980s, computers were increasingly installed by hospitals.
The focus was largely on the revenue producing departments such as billing,
laboratory, pharmacy, and radiology.
They and the nurses stations where orders originate,
and to wish results are sent,
needed to share information.
Often, each of these departments was using a specialized,
independently developed, not interoperable proprietary software module.
This led to the formation of HL7 and the development of its messaging standards.
Using this technology, a physician could
order a lab test or medication at the nurses' station.
And as shown here,
that order could go electronically to the clinical laboratory to do the test,
or to the pharmacy to deliver the medication.
In the case of a test,
the results could come back to the nurses' station
using a different message from the same standard.
The next evolution was standards for clinical documents.
A message would typically be an order for a single lab tests or medication.
However, the physician who would care for a patient after hospital discharge,
requires a complete summary of that patient's care.
This is the role of document standards.
You worked with one of them,
the HL7 CCD, in the health fault exercise.
As is often the case with standards,
more than one was developed by different organizations, as shown here.
Today, they've been reconciled into
the Consolidated Clinical Document Architecture, or CCDA.
However, you may still run into a CCR,
CDA, or C32 formatted clinical document.
More recently, as computers have become even more powerful,
standards have been evolving to represent clinical processes and workflows.
We will not cover these standards in any detail,
but IHE is an initiative by healthcare professionals and
industry to improve the way computer systems and healthcare share information.
Here's an example from IHE of schedule workflow,
SWF, that integrates the ordering,
scheduling, imaging acquisition, storage,
and viewing activities associated with radiology exams.
Analysis of this workflow leads to identification of
the actors and transactions needed to accomplish the task.
Properly implemented, these standards could provide benefits including
greater efficiency and a reduction in errors
caused by unnecessary variations in patient care.
Implementation does involve many areas of the hospital and many systems,
so it requires a concerted effort.
Nevertheless, given the cost of modern imaging equipment,
this is a good use case.
The IHE radiology group says that hundreds of
commercial radiology-related information systems have incorporated its solutions.